hearing morning believe nation today's
message is your destiny is in your hands
over to you Alan sugar are don't wish to
alienate people here we're about what
I'm about to say but you know your
destiny is in your hands and I had
succeeded because I had to no one
salted anything out for me I didn't ask
go to any government and said pretty
please find me some work please and do
something for me because it was a waste
of bloody time simply that a waste of
time and if I was going to do something
I had to do it myself that's it and and
I would say to every one of you here
don't sit around relying upon magically
some government going to create an
environment that's going to make it easy
for you to find work and find jobs
you've got to go out there and fight for
it yourself I'm sorry to say I can't
give you any other any other form of
advice
if you want something bad enough you do
it and if you look at some of these
wannabes that make themselves television
stars or and pop stars and all that type
of stuff they have a desire to want to
be famous and they don't stop until
they're recognized and they do and half
the people that you see on television
these days in the entertainment industry
are those that added determination that
wanted to do it and I'll add a little
rider to that none of them can bloody
sing
not helpful right I mean you didn't find
that helpful answer but you're gonna
control your destiny I'm telling you no
one else is gonna do it not unless
you've got a Rich Dad
have you got a rich dad a rich uncle no
well then that's it you're gonna have to
do it yourself so you think yeah I think
if you want to make something happen
it's up to you it's with your hands
which I'm a big fan of the power is in
your hands so this message to me it
really speaks to me for sure I think we
were chatting about environment how
important that is I think too many
people blame their circumstances on why
they're not successful you know you have
these big dreams for what you want to
accomplish and you say well I can't do
that because my family isn't the right
family or I don't have the right
education or I'm not smart enough write
all about money to do it and it's just a
constant blaming of the circumstances in
your environment as opposed to you
saying I'm responsible for what I want
to do and not blaming other people it's
easy to blame right you never gonna
blame yourself you're not going to say
oh I'm the reason why I'm not successful
it's always the government or taxes or
something we blaming somebody else but
the moment that you take responsibility
for your life realize that a lot of the
most successful people in the world rose
out of terrible circumstances and they
wouldn't have done that they just
continue to believe that they're there
where they were born is where they're
gonna end up and I think the message is
sin don't worry if you if you take
responsibility if you actually believe
that you can can
to your future and you start acting that
way and stop blaming other people then
you're much more likely to realize your
dreams totally agree yeah let go of that
victim mentality I think sometimes we
don't realize we're even doing it like
we're mad at something that our boss
says to us or that our client did to us
and if we just kind of reframe it in our
head and think about what we can do to
change it then you know all of a sudden
you realize you have power in your hands
cool so the question that they today is
what are you gonna do to change your
destiny I like that one we're going deep
10 Texas deep leaving the comments below
will join the discussion thank you so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso